[Music]
hello and welcome to playstation grenade
borderlands 3 brings us four brand
spanking new vault hunters to choose
from on our trek around the galaxy
zayn mo's amara and flack over the past
few months i've been lucky enough to
play them all
and i thought i'd mention a few things
to help you decide which fault hunter
is best for you before we start you need
to know that there is no wrong choice
here there is no bad decision you're
gonna love borderlands
3 regardless of which vault hunter you
choose they're all complete op wrecking
balls
by the end of the video we should pick
our characters and i'm hoping you'll
write yours in the comments below
and more importantly tell us why you
chose that character
i really want to know what makes them
great to you i've broken this video into
sections each one listed in the
description below
so you can decide which element is more
important to you first we'll give a
character bio for each of the hunters
and where they link him with law of
borderlands then we'll look at how they
interact with the world
and their voice acting the next step
will be to go through their skills and
unique abilities
and there's a few annoyances which could
impact your decision so i'll put those
in too
and finally we'll look at how the
impacts play in co-op or solo
there is so much to get through so if
you're ready let's do this
next level if a character's backstory is
key to your decision and how they fit in
with law
this section is for you meet amara who's
a siren
amara is a tough sob who is itching for
a fight
i mean the first thing her character bio
has her say is this
i'm always looking for a fight
a fight for justice a fight for what's
right
amara is super aggressive and with that
comes a confidence we rarely see in
female video game protagonists
even the queen of the female lead
characters lara croft
always has the air of self-doubt to
overcome whereas
amara is 100 dedicated to her work and
just wants to punch people
in the name of doing the right thing
amara has the deepest link to
borderlands law
due to her siren status sirens are the
most powerful creatures in the
borderlands universe
their powers are mythic but here's the
thing
there can only be six sirens in
existence at any one time
and another thing all sirens are female
sirens can be easily identified by their
tattoo-like markings around their arms
and torso
thus far we know of six women to be
classified as sirens
angel who died in the previous game
commandant steele who
died in a previous game the next three
are maya from borderlands 2 lilith the
leader of the crimson raiders the
faction we belong to in borderlands 3
and of course amara the playable siren
in bottle and three
and finally tyreen calypso who is our
arch enemy this time around
let's not go too far down this rabbit
hole but know that sirens are pivotal to
the story being told
in borderland 3. if you want a front row
seat choose
amara from a law standpoint she's the
right pick
next up is zayn how can i quickly get
his
character across imagine han solo and
boba fett
put into the same character with colin
farrell's irish
accent zane's history spans the galaxy
he attended the same assassin school as
zero from borderlands 2
but he's also aligned himself on both
sides of the law in the past
he's completely untrustworthy and
prefers his own company to that of
others
and is happy to take on any work he can
making his moral compass
difficult to read at best rest assured
though in borderlands 3 he's a good guy
through
and through zayn could be the new merc
with a mouth from a last standpoint
zane's surname may ring a bell or two
flint
zayn has two brothers we've already met
baron flint was a bandit
well baron we fought and killed in the
original borderlands then in borderlands
2 we took on captain flint
who has an addiction to torturing people
we killed him too by the way
come to think of it does zayn know he's
working for the organization that
murdered both of his brothers
that could be an awkward conversation
character three is mose a former soldier
who's fought in many wars
the story is quite sorrowful her final
mission drew close
dazaran bay completing this task would
result in her earning the mech she
fights in
as severance pay as she left the war
behind her
but it turns out that mose and her unit
were sent to an impossible mission they
were sent to die
their last mission saw a skyscraper
toppled on top of their heads
somehow though moe's survived now she's
off the grid she's battle-hardened and
ready for a fight
with her mech mose decides to become a
vault hunter
her connections to the borderlands law
are through her association with the
world's most well-known gun manufacturer
vladov the vladov brand is designed to
mimic russian military conventions
with the company looking to arm rebels
and enemy forces to his competitors
it's even implied that moles and her
unit were deliberately killed by their
employers to prevent them from switching
sides after they left the military
this may even be a story beat in the
game and finally
flack off flak fork fla fork
uh anyway by far flak is the hardest to
sum up on this list
and there's no links to laura either
he's an emergent ai
so should i say they are an emergent ai
she she is an emergent
it isn't is you know what i really don't
care as long as flak is a badass
character i couldn't give a sh
i'm gonna go with he as he's voiced by a
man
and the mocap is using a male actor and
his body looks suspiciously like my fat
ass
if that gender pronoun offends you well
this isn't the video for you
okay he's a fictional robot let's move
on
flack is borderlands first beast master
somehow flack is able to communicate
with the world's creatures and persuade
them
to follow his lead he uses a pack
mentality which means
there is an alpha animal who controls
the herd's actions but ultimately
he's a hunter with a pet i've tried my
best to tie in the law to him but i can
i can't find anything
so arguably black is the perfect
character to choose if you're completely
new to the borderlands series
so now we have a basis to work from
character histories so let's move on to
interactions
borderlands 3 has given vault hunters
far more lines than they ever had before
and although they are inserted into the
exact same conversations they
all vary massively and remember you'll
be stuck with that character's voice for
around 35
hours so if you're not too fond of it
it's best to know that from minute one
here's what all the vault hunters sound
like what's your name
you are allowed to call me flack until i
decide if i'm going to kill you
thanks what's your name amara
thanks what's your name moe's
gunner first class x blad off mechanized
infantry
amara seems to be short and to the point
she doesn't seem to give away much of
her character in terms of emotion
she's more sassy as the game progresses
but from what i've played she speaks the
least
here's another example of how amara is
short and swift with her responses
is this gigamind something i could punch
now compare that same scenario with zayn
that is our mission gigamind of course
i know it well mind explaining for
anyone who doesn't though i didn't
not not me of course the difference is
night and day
character interactions play a huge part
in borderlands 3.
from my time with zayn i can say that
his lapsidasical responses will always
grab your attention
whereas amara's sometimes just pass you
by without you realizing
so what's your crazy deal moe's is quite
military focused due to her background
but that becomes less prominent as the
character evolves cool
dig all that i'm supposed to give you a
message
flax responses are more amusing than you
would think from an objective
ai supposedly without emotion his desire
to hunt comes across regularly but in
terms of character
he's like tealq from stargate is that
reference far too old
your clan is dead tyreen calypso
slaughtered them
it was unnatural he's very matter of
fact but he's got lots of charisma too
i mean check out how he speaks to the
game's sexiest character
ellie hey what are you staring at hun
most humans are frail and weak but
you've got
admirable heft girl ain't you a
heartbreaker
so we now know the character's history
we know how they talk and interact with
the world
so let's move on to something which
really impacts your decision each hunter
has drastically different skills which
affect your playstyle the
only skill they all share is shooting a
billion guns here's how the abilities
change your game
as a note there are too many passive
perks to go through like increased
accuracy limiting cooldowns or upping
damage no that sort of thing so we'll
just concentrate on the ones which are
very different
from each other so back to amara let's
go through her
siren abilities her three action skills
can be changed on the fly
but she can only equip one at any point
her first ability is
face slam in which amara jumps in the
air and smashes to the ground
like a superhero landing creating an
area of effect damage zone
great for taking out groups of foes the
splash damage of this move
can be buffed to make it even wider and
it's also possible to change the element
used
like this lovely corrosive green as her
skills level up and upgrade
amara learns to summon fists to fracture
the ground in front of her
and it's even possible for amara to fire
an elemental beam
at the ground before she lands that slam
facelam has a cooldown of 26 seconds in
between uses
her second ability is phase cast which
allows amara to throw out an astral
projection of herself
and it literally flies straight as an
arrow through enemies in its path
it's wider than you think picking up
collateral damage on limbs and any part
of the enemy which touches its vicinity
the distance strength and how it passes
through cover can all be upgraded in the
skill tree
with one cool perk which gives amara and
allies health for successful face casts
perfect for co-op play the standard
cooldown is 22 seconds in between uses
amara's final ability is phase grasp
which is ridiculous fun
amara summons a giant fist which holds
an enemy in place unable to move
this is great to use on boss like
characters to deal huge damage while
they are helpless
as a basis the hold lasts for 7 seconds
and then there's a 13 second cooldown
before we can use it again
the skill can be converted to solar or
fire damage if you prefer
and as it's upgraded more fists join the
party allowing more enemies to be
grabbed
and one perk even allows us to shoot one
enemy and all the other ones take the
same damage from it
pretty damn cool of course there are
gives and takes to all these skills and
for every vault hunter actually
cooldowns change as attacks become more
op but one thing for sure
you feel like a complete badass playing
as amara
next up is zayn here's something to know
right away about this irishman
he can have two abilities active at the
same time
no other vault hunter can do this it's
so damn good it really is
but the problem is if you choose two
abilities he loses
his grenades they're completely gone and
as you can tell by my channel name
grenades are important to me so is it
worth it
well well yes check this out zayn can
summon a sentinel drone which
continuously flies around the
battlefield and automatically attacks
enemies
with its mounted machine guns by
pressing l2 and r2 together the drone
will target whoever zane is looking at
at first the damage isn't great but as
you would expect this can be upgraded
through the skill trees
at its base sentinel is a 60 second
skill 24 seconds in the air before 36
seconds of cooldown between uses
the skill tree here is very interesting
as the passive skills include the
ability to swap weapons quicker
and increase the damage in different
ways the drone can also be specced for
cryo damage
and lifesteal is here too allowing zayn
to regain health from enemies
zayn's second skill is digi clone just
as the name suggests
a clone is digistructed and stays in
place he fires at enemies and those
enemies will focus on the clone instead
of the real zane
who can be moving around at this point
this skill is so good for getting out of
tight fights on low health
zayn can then switch places with the
clone at any point almost like having
two characters at the same time
a one-man flanking maneuver it's like an
instant teleport too
i used this in a boss fight in which the
weak spot was on his back
with the digiclone the boss would focus
on him and then the real zane would
creep around the back and shoot him up
the arse
at first the clone lasts 18 seconds with
a 26 second cooldown in between uses
one of the upgrades allows zane and the
clone to be awarded an increased
magazine size
perfect for going up against multiple
enemies finally zane's last
skill is a defensive barrier that lasts
9 seconds initially and then cools down
for 18 seconds before we can pop it
again
the greatest thing about this ability is
that we can shoot through this barrier
the whole squad can shoot out of the
shield but the bandits can't shoot
through it
one of the standout perks gives zayn and
allies increased maneuverability and
fire rate for a short time after
touching that shield
and on the flip side a deterrence field
can be unlocked which passes
shock damage to enemies who touch the
shield freaking awesome isn't it
oh and earlier when i said no grenades
if you use two skills simultaneously
well when the drone is upgraded it will
randomly drop nades on enemies
and the clone will leave an aid behind
when it's destroyed grenade for life
next let's break down moe's even though
most has three skill trees they're all
really just
one to summon the mech known as the iron
bear but each of those trees
comes down to how you want to spec the
bear mowers can opt for a semi-automatic
grenade launcher to be added
a rail gun that makes high-velocity
shock bolts
or a minigun for sustained rapid fire
all
unbelievably fun to use upgrades as
you'd expect are all about damage and
decreasing the cooldown of the mech
and increasing how long it's in the
fight for the iron bear can be specced
out perfectly
for every single battle for example
taking on a huge number of enemies spec
towards a wider damage effect
focusing on a single target the railgun
will obliterate them
it may seem as if moses is a
two-dimensional character but this class
for those who want it is the perfect
weaponized
tank oh and the greatest upgrade of all
a second seat for your teammate to jump
in
this is so much fun and cooperative so
many left to be had when playing in
co-op
and finally the enigma that is flack
black has three pets to choose from a
skag
a jabber or a spider ant flak can only
choose one though
making the decision can be down to the
skill trees or more realistically
which one looks cute is to you the skill
trees although they're linked to the pet
you can technically pick one pet and
spec a different tree
i don't know why you'd want to do that
but it is possible but realistically
each pet has its own skill tree which
sees them evolve
and become highly skilled killing
machines the way evolution works
is really fun the jammer skill tree
first gives the little monkey
lion thing as pistol but through
evolution he becomes a beefcake
java and the pistol is changed out for a
shotgun
then later in the skill tree the jabber
becomes a gunslinger
with an smg to mess up your enemies and
at that level the jabber also gets a
rocket launcher
things are crazy in this skill tree the
jabba can also be spec
to res you if you're knocked down in
battle the same skill tree gives flack
another ability an invisibility cloak
just like in the predator movies
while cloaked flak can fire three shots
which regardless of where they hit will
be awarded
critical bonuses for additional damage
there's a few different ways to spec the
invisibility cloak for example you
could technically play in a stealthy way
and avoid enemies up until the boss
battles
the hunter tree focuses on the spider
ant but flexibility in this line is a
rack attack
sending out a flying beast to attack
enemies the spider ant can be upgraded
to be a scorcher
which adds incendiary damage to your pet
and its final evolution is a countess
allowing the spider ant to burrow under
the ground
then when it emerges it will drop a
corrosive area of effect
to decimate bandits the final skill tree
gives us a skag as a pet
which will throw up acid on command
lovely flax ability allows him to
teleport the pet
gifting it radiation damage so if the
skag has run too far away
bring him back with this teleportation
trick after evolution the sky can rush
enemies and flip them into the air
and the final evolution allows the skag
to drag all enemies closer to him
using a singularity pulse it's
interesting isn't it there are so many
small changes which impact gameplay
within all these skill trees but i think
our heads would explode
if we went any further into this right
now hopefully though one of these
characters grabbed your attention and
you are one step closer to choosing your
first vault hunter in borderlands 3.
as a side point there are a few things i
think you should be aware of which can
be annoying and put you off certain
characters
but don't worry nothing's game breaking
but it can frustrate you at times so i
thought at least i'd let you know
flax pets they're freaking awesome yeah
i love them but the problem is when
you're interacting with npcs or trying
to get yourself into the story
they walk around the scene and become a
distraction worst of all though can be
the audio shrieks that they let out for
no reason
at all hopefully they're patched out but
to me the worst thing was the way they
clicked through objects
or frustratingly of all clips through
the person you are talking to
like i say it's not game breaking but
definitely bloody annoying if you're
trying to get yourself into the story
and immersion is your thing
next is moe's and her mech frustratingly
the mech can get stuck in places
it happens it's one of those things or
there won't be enough room to actually
use it
mid-fights that's annoying too but the
only thing i really want to say is that
there are worlds with bridges with small
gaps
seemingly too small for a 10-foot mech
to fit through
but no a two-foot gap can see the iron
bear fall into the abyss
being stuck then falling to your death
can be super aggravating
to my knowledge i haven't seen any
issues with amara or zane but please
note
there's not big deals these things
they're just slightly immersion breaking
issues which cause frustrations
i think they're all forgivable but
personally those pets running around
were so annoying
so that put me off black and finally
if you're planning to play solo or
cooperatively there are certain builds
and hunters which will be perfect for
you
of course all hunters are great in both
scenarios but here's a few things to
note
solo players you should consider flack
as the strongest option
due to his pets it's ultimately like
playing duos with an ai
that way you don't have to talk to real
people also by selecting the jabber
skill tree he can be upgraded to
automatically res black if he is downed
the pets can also gain aggro allowing
flak to escape and the evolutions of the
pets make them so op
flack is perfect for solo play almost
all of his perks apply to him and not
really his allies
even though i do recommend him for solo
play two flaks playing together with two
pets running around
makes this game ridiculously easy on the
other hand a character which is perfect
for duo play is
moz primarily due to the iron bear mech
and the ability to add a second seat for
another vault hunter to jump in
the way she can spec her weapons allows
for interesting builds which can cover
allies with the barrage of different
splash damages
whilst using highly directable weapons
for dps stages when her partner has the
aggro of a boss
moe's has a staggering amount of
adjustments to suit cooperative play
in solos she lacks defensive options and
maneuvering items
but still great fun in solo but i'd have
to say it's a little harder to play as
moe's so if you want a challenge
pick mo's in solo play and then we have
amara and zayn who both have attributes
which help in solo and cooperative play
amara is slightly more solo focused due
to her aggressive actions but due to her
links with the storyline and being a
siren she's always a great option at
every single opportunity which leads me
to zayn
zayn's two active abilities offer team
play extensive benefits
the flying drone to watch over allies
the digi clone to allow for quick
teleportation to cover your teammate
and the shield barrier which allows
allies to shoot through without taking
damage
all perfect for co-op play on the flip
side the same skills when spec'd
right can make zayn unbeatable in solo
play
the clone offers a way to flank enemies
safely the shield keeps snipers at bay
in intense battles and the drone is the
extra touch of safety
needed when playing alone if zayn uses
the drone
and clone technology at the same time
it's like having three players
shooting simultaneously rewarded with
massive dps
this video has been far too long so
let's cut this here who the heck are you
going to pick
i realized when i was about midway
through this video that i've already
chosen
i'm going to pick zayn the irish han
solo of borderlands
of course that's only one man's thoughts
who is the right vault hunter for you
i'd really love to know i'll be looking
in the comments to see who you guys
prefer and more importantly
why you chose that vault hunter
hopefully this video was helpful thank
you very much for your time it's been a
pleasure
i'm adam from playstation grenade i'll
see you next time
good